foreign
Ukrainian forces are always on alert
we have been granted exclusive access to
one of their secret hideouts the
ukrainians say the battles on the
southern front of kerson are going in
their favor
this is the closest point between
Ukrainian and Russian forces on the
front line we were allowed to film this
mobile artillery as it was preparing to
fire Russian targets
the soldiers have covered it with
branches it's hidden they're hiding it
from an enemy they themselves can't see
the team Commander oversees every move
because on the front line there is no
room for error
the Russians are on the opposite side at
this moment their exact locations being
sent to us via radio then the order to
fire will be issued
moments later a shell is launched
everything shakes
then another
this footage shows the Ukrainian Army
bombing Russian locations
elsewhere there are U.S supplied
howitzers part of the military aid from
Washington
Ukrainian artillery hit Russian Targets
in eastern Herson but the Russians
respond by bombing this city residential
areas and infrastructure
the war is spreading
and the Russian shelling doesn't stop in
the city center
some areas of Curson look like a ghost
town tens of thousands of people have
left but others remain hopes that the
war will be over quickly are fading
Curson fell soon after Russia invaded in
February 2022
Ukraine retook the city late last year
Russian troops withdrew to the Eastern
Bank of the tadipra river which flows
through the province Carousel is
important because of its location
it has access to the Black Sea and the
Sea of azov and of course the Crimean
peninsula
Tamir al-samadi Al Jazeera kersan